why why should i have to deal with your
your issues after you've just
you had the chance when you was 21 the
chance when you was 22 23 20. now i'm
gonna go club i wanna do this i wanna
please babes i wanna wife you no no no i
ain't got time for you
do you know on the count of three
everyone shout out their body count five
but do you get my point um
do you get my point if it's
no you're not ashamed of it because it's
five yeah if it was 55 you'd stay quiet
yeah
no you would stay
quiet if i was 55 it wouldn't have it
wouldn't necessarily me staying quiet
because we know what the um
what it's like like it's not it's not a
bad thing necessarily for me to be
sleeping around can i just say something
that i am
myself obviously i've had long-term
relationships so i'm fine but
what i will say is for the younger
generation
it's very difficult to have a low body
count now because and it's it's because
of older women not even
you lied to the younger women
no cause you wanted them to wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait can i just
say that
can i just let me just say something you
got time
like you're saying dating and we're
saying connections and we're giving out
all this there's so many people the
social media has ruined dating it's like
there's so much variety there's so much
what you should be expecting what you
shouldn't be expecting so
it's so fickle dating is so fickle now
how how are young girls expected to keep
their body count down
when but
there's there's no relationships now
like it's not like back in the day where
you had a long-term life relationship
mostly our age were the last of the
long-term relationships i'm not gonna
lie well men men have definitely dropped
their standards for what they used to
accept a girl used to be a host she
slept with more than two people now a
guy prays for five
listen and i've seen i've seen guys
i've seen a lot of hosts got wifed a lot
that's true
but they're also the first divorced
because i always say a woman sleeping
around it hurts herself more than anyone
else because it impacts her ability to
pair bond
so women have a hard time staying when
they've slept with too many people
statistically because yeah because women
that have slept with more than five men
yeah their their chance of a happy
marriage drops from about one eighty
percent after ten years they're going to
be in a happy marriage to 30
after five partners after 10 years so i
can't sleep with any more guys or else
i'm going to drop in the possession
that is like work so i need to find my
husband right now
no more
sex but that's what i'm saying is like
there's reasons behind it
do you think do you think that's gonna
work
no more sex yeah dude like that's what i
mean when i say you making him wait and
you're making him wait
the guy
i'm just going to have to go back to
someone i've had sex with
yeah that's what i said that's why you
should have married your partner
oh come on man no no that's not i know
you explained it to me but that's why at
first i said you should have married
your partner if you married your partner
in year one you would have divorced when
your problems happened but you would
have been married
but what's that that's just no i mean i
don't listen i grew up here i grew up
let me let me give you this i don't know
if it's my cousin's fault i blame her um
i was a protestant in scotland as
protestant catholics my cousin was a
catholic as a protestant she got to make
a communion and i didn't
she religiously i stayed at her house
and most days when my mom was working
she used to dress me in a trouser suit
and she dressed up in her communion
dress and made us play weddings like in
the living in front of everyone and it
really daunted me that she always made
me be the guy like it hurt me a lot so i
just was like i hate weddings
i don't know if it's instilled i haven't
ever had the wish to be married i don't
dream of the white dress i don't at the
commitment that is for the government to
say you're married like i dream of real
love like that's all i've ever done but
marriage marriage is a business and it's
a business and you're right and when i
left i realized that i failed in that
business transaction mm-hmm yeah because
he held most of the mon the money but i
think that's like the what we have
confused as women is we're we're in it
for love but it's not about love it's
about what works long term and building
family and i hear you and i hear you and
i hear what you're saying and for my
my beautiful daughters i did stay a lot
lot lot longer than i should have a lot
longer but when they got to a certain
age
and maturity and i realized that this
was actually affecting them because i
didn't want what i realized is i thought
was acceptable because i'd seen my
parents
do similar things so i thought that was
acceptable i'd never seen i've nev i've
never seen a
one nurturing relationship i'm not sure
you don't have to save what wasn't
acceptable
yeah
it's it's not acceptable so i didn't
want my daughters to then i i think
sometimes we rerun our parents
relationship no no i said no because
you're not allowed to say that word oh
oh you're not okay yeah so i just felt
like i'd
see i just felt like i thought it was
acceptable because i grew up seeing it
so therefore i didn't want them to think
that was acceptable that was how
relationships were supposed to be so i
decided not to do it and when you said
to me 18 years you should have stayed no
way
i believe in if if it's unhappy it
affects your kids worse
in the case of abuse i would agree with
you yeah and abuse but i think that's
more of the exception rather than the
rule
because women leave 70 to 80 of the time
90 if we're college educated
and one of the number one predictors of
if you're going to get a divorce is if
you out earn your husband
do you think that's because of the women
or because of the men i think it's
because women are hypergamous and it's
hard for a woman to be attracted to a
guy she makes more than
really because in my personal
circumstances the issue i've always had
is a man not being secure enough to
accept the fact that i've done better
than that absolutely i think i think the
problem is you've done better but yeah
that's that's the problem is like women
and it kind of shows in the way you talk
respectfully like it sounds like you
like yeah it sounds like you're acting
like you're better than me yeah that's
that's not what i mean yeah but i'm
saying a lot of like women
unintentionally act like they're better
than the guy and then it makes him
insecure
but so the way you look is i like for me
personally obviously everyone's
different but for me personally when i'm
looking for a guy
i care about
if what they're doing they have passion
for what they're doing they have drive
for what they're doing regardless of how
they are financially because when you're
with somebody you're a couple right
you're a team in that so it doesn't
matter who the higher earner is it
matters if they can provide you with
that emotional support and that
stability and i think that sounds nice
but that's just not women what women
pick and i think when we say things like
that it's dishonest but it's because
it's it it is what happens no because
women when you survey women where
they're not in front of them on camera
with mics in their faces
they say they want a guy that makes at
least 30 more than that they say this
this is from the horse's mouth okay as
yeah of course i've never dated a guy
that's that's kind of uh more than i
have well i mean you also aren't married
though so you didn't stay with one
even kind of aligns with my experience
so nigerian background the last
generation of nigerians were very like
you know pioneers they did very very
well goldman sachs and all the women
especially the women who did really well
are like
found it extremely hard to settle down
because of that reason they all said
uh i need i need someone who's like i'm
better than me he's like earns more than
me and these women were like top lawyers
like they were like killing it and there
were all these guys they had all the
options they had the looks they had all
the physical assets that men liked and
they struggled for decades in some cases
and i think some of them still aren't
married now because and you know
nigerians is very vocal so you go into
family you know reunions and weddings
and they weren't they weren't shy of
saying yeah like if you don't and if you
can't compete with me earnings wise i've
got twin sister and you know
even then you kind of hear those kind of
sentiments
um or this idea that like if you settle
for someone who you know it doesn't end
as much reason as successful as you are
that you're like settling and this is
this could be like a six foot four
muscle-bound uni educated women always i
mean why do we know the phrase we know
this phrase when i say oh i want a man
on my level women say that all the time
you don't hear men saying oh i want a
woman on my level what do you think
that's because i think it's because
women are hypergamous and men aren't
women want a guy that they they can look
up to i don't think it's a bad thing
that's okay i think it's okay i actually
agree with that phrase i want a guy on
my level but that doesn't come down to a
monetary value
alone
money muscles frame and game